- Une cérémonie d'ouverture
le long de la Seine, certaines
compétitions dans des décors
à coulelele souffle.
En plus d'être spectaculaires,
les organisateurs de Paris 2024
promettent des jeux qui
respecteront l'environnement
p p p profiteront à la populat.
ANNE HIDALGO, mairesse de Paris
- Ces Jeux, on les veut
inclusifs, on les veut ouverts,
on les veut en partage.
- Mais à l'ombre de Paris,
comme ici, dans la banlieue
de Saint-Denis, certains projets
dérangent. C'est le cas
de cette future bretelle
d'autoroute qui permettra
de mieux desservir le village
olympique.
Un projet de 95 millions
d'euros prévu depuis des années,
que les bulilililiés aux JO
ont permis de financer.
HAMID OUIDIR, parent d'élèves
de Saint-Denis, France
- Nous sommes en droit,
ququququque citoyens,
en tant qu'habitants,
en tant que parents,
de dire "non stop".
- Une fois l'échangeur terminé,
les voitures cntntntntnt
quotidiennement à quelques
mètres à peine de l'école
maternelle et primaire, qui sera
enclavée par des axes routiers.
En plus d'enjeux liés
àcucucucucurité, Hamid Ouidir,
père de deux élèves, craint
les impacts cette circulation
dans un quartier déjà pollué.
- La loi olympique votée
au parlement en France,
elle vous autorise à expulser
ou à exproprier juste pour
accélérer des projets, mais vous
a jamais autorisé à asphyxier
des gami u u u u un quartier.
- La ville de Saint-Denis
n'a pas répondu à notre demande
d'entrevue. Les autorités
assurent que l'école sera
séparée de l'infrastructure
par un écran de verdure, et que
l'échangeur permettra d'apaiser
la circulation sur d'autres axes
routiers de la municipalité.
Il n'y a pas qu'à Saint-Denis
qu'un projet lié aux Jeux
Olympiques fait l'objet
de contestation.
Ici, dans la ville voisine
d'Aubervilliers, un groupe
de citoyens s'oppose
à la construction
d'une infrastructure sportive.
La piscine d'entraînement
est déjà à l'état de chantier.
Le problème, c'est qu'elle
amputera des milliers de mètres
carrés des jardins ouvriers,
un espace communautaire qui
existe depuis une centaine
d'années.
Dolores Mijatovic, qui possède
une partie du jardin, fait
partie d'un groupe de citoyens
qui milite pour faire cesser
les travaux. Certains se sont
même récemment encha
aux équipements de construction
pour empêcher au béton
de couler.
DOLORÈS MIJATOVIC, collectif de
Défense des Jartrtrtrtrtrtrtus
- Nous, on étouffe ici,en fait,
l'été quand il fait chaud, on
étouffe l'été, donc on a besoin
d'espace non bétonné. On n'a pas
besoinbébébébébébébéton qui fera
plus de chaleur, qui fera plus
d'air irrespirable. Ce n'est
pas. Je veux dire. Il n'y a pas
à chercher loin pour se dire que
ususususususus précieux de nous
laisser la terre des jardins que
de mettre du béton dessus.
- Un tribunal a récemment
demandé aux autorités de revoirt
du projet sur la biodiversité.
Pour l'instant, la construction
se poursuit.
KARINE FRANCLET, mairesse
d'Aubervilliers, France
- À terme, la surface
des jardins prise par
la piscine, elle sera
reconstituée sur un ancien
terrain de football.
- La mairesse d'Aubervilliers
nous a accordé une entrevue
avant que la justice se prononce
sur la question.
Karine Franclet défend
ce projet, que son prédécesseur
a négocié.
Elle assure que les immenses
budgets liés aux JO profiteront
à sa communauté.
- On a absolument besoin
d'infrastructures sportives
et notamment de piscine
parce qu'en Seine-Saint-Denis,
à l'entrée en sixième,
les enfants de 12 ans,
c'est seulement un sur deux
qui ne savent pas nager.
Donc, oui, les JO
l'opportunité de pouvoir
avoir des équipements.
Un paysage transformé,
mais aussi une crainte
d'une gentrificationr.r.r.r.r.r.
Si Dolores Mijatovic ne s'oppose
pas aux Jeux, elle craint
leur impact dans les banlieues.
- J'ai envie de dire :
ça s'appelle JO Paris 2024.IcIc,
en fait. Ici, c'est la Seine
Saint-Denis. Ça ne s'appelle pas
les JO de la Seine Saint-Denis,
en fait, c'est JO Paris,
et ça vient détruire ici.
- Les organisateurs
et les autorités publiques
ont un peu plus de deux ans
pour convaincre les sceptiques
que leur région ne sortira pas
perdante de ces compét
Ici Raphaël Bouvier-Auclair,
R